もう政府動かし禁止から1月の最初に初めて
234もう3ヶ月お菓子金賞をやってます肇社長ですお菓子騎士してからやっぱでも
痩せるのが目的じゃないっけせるのが目的じゃなくて真の目的はその体調身体の体調
良くしたいというのが目的だったんで結構体は多分多少なりともよくなってると思うん
ですけども
俺にはポンポン的で直さなきゃいけなくなるとねそれなんかそ普段のご飯つオレカ熟女
普段からご飯を作らない人生行きたくないんだから当選可否そいつも品ミニでごはん
食べますよくない非常に受けた非常に良くないんですけどもだからねちょっとねどう
しようかなと思ってた矢先にドンキですごいものにつきました郊外の商品は
コンピューターじゃん
お一人塗るメーカーお一人様なんですね
go
う一例ようなんだ相手レコのヌードルメーカー何かといいますとなんとラーメンを
作れるみたいです名前の通り
すごいと思いますあのカップねあそぼその僕あんまり食べないんですよブランディング
が好きだからよく夜中にラーメン屋さんとか言って友だちとラーメン食っちゃうんでな
のでその鍋を食べに来て待つラン省けサルってもう撮っておきないと言うんですよこれ
さやでもう家でひとりでラーメンが来るかも知れませんからね
オープンあっ本分
嫁だけだ釣ったこれ2で本体電源スイッチコードハイサイ探偵なお湯が沸かせたまずは
水を入れますけど水は0.3 l クレジットだから適当でいい人ですね沸騰し始め
たら良いスタートらー名を入れます蓋をして出てくださいお湯を沸かす作業から始め
ましょうよ
よし早速渡しましょうどう能なんか沸騰前から沸騰するみたいな感じになってますこれ
信じてるよ
5分待ってみましょうで僕はこの5分の間にラーメン買いに行かなきゃ
いたーーーパンッ
沸騰するのでごラーメン入れちゃいますを入れます
教師免許に出るまで待ちますそれはかな
かろうじて超まってまってまってまっぴーまっぴーまっぴーます
爆爆爆これを突くねマスクにこれを付け
なんか今のあーまでた無炭酸でも持ってくれてよ
そんな雰囲気ですちょっとまずもう少し待ちましょう
[音楽]
much much much
抹茶抹茶これ炭酸かなぁ絶対炭酸がいいんだよねなんでだろすっ原爆ボックスんだけど
[音楽]
ピッパ
けっこうこれこういう主要なのかなぁねこういう主要な気がしてきちゃったよ
あぶなは中田さんとか関係なく普通に溢れ出てるんではいというわけでなった命は
たぶんできました
ただなぁまつげなく炭酸抜けてるはこれ便利だわそのまま食べるっていうのはすごい
大きいですねどうせだったら炭酸が見たれたいんで
以下ちょっとここに水を入れますポケモンて完成を入れて温めまして僕多分猫舌なんで
このまま食べてもあつって食べれないんでこっちの水を切ってでこっちの今ターン性が
ほどよい温度になってからこっちに打つ
こちらとした後にれ機体スープを入れて本当は美味しいちょうどいい緩い女の炭酸
ラーメン食べましょう
これで暖かい
単3を4をスープとステップ作れますとで液体スープを入れますというで完成しました
こちらターン3ラーメンでございます
いただきます
[音楽]
運命ごちそうさまでしたさあさあみなさんここで今日も理科の話のターン水を加熱する
登坂散水はどうなるか知ってるから炭酸が抜けるんだ
ヌードな音がすごい便利でしただから名誉をそのままパッとしてパってくれるんで
めんどくされる僕にはとても良いものでした鳥暮らしの寂しいそんな君も良かったら
使ってみてくださいじゃない